foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
airports and golf shoes
man that's right everyone's been
interested in
airports and golf shoes
the queen is still making her way around
the UK
Donald Trump made his way back to
Washington we don't know why there's a
lot of speculation on why Donald Trump's
in Washington it sounds like Jared
Kushner has a
he has he has an event
he has an America First Nazi Rally or
something I don't I don't know I mean
that's that's when I have to question
that's where I go with it
and I'm serious it's an America first
thing
I'm not I'm not [ __ ] you it's
it's a fascist thing I mean Jared
Kushner
is now a full-on fascist they're not
semi-fascists by the way
the right wing
it's still
so pissed off
about Joe Biden
calling Trump supporters semi-fascist
you bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] what are
you talking why are you so mad that Joe
Biden called you semi-fascists like he's
being nice he's being nice to you
I won't be now I don't give a [ __ ] I
won't be nice
he's being nice to you when he calls you
a semi-fascist he's being nice to you
you're a [ __ ] Nazi if you still
support these treasonous bastards
this morning
Trump
files his rebuttal his motion
and says you prove prove that they're
classified
and oh by the way they're mine they're
not yours they're not yours it's not
your [ __ ] it's our [ __ ] it's the
government [ __ ]
and the burden of proof is on you dummy
you're the one who said you waved your
Big Mac stained hands or these documents
and Declassified them of course
everyone's still saying this [ __ ] as if
this is the way that it actually is and
as if
even though this information is
Declassified that makes it better
why why the [ __ ] do you think it makes
it better
so we have that to deal with today
we have a special guest with us today
a political strategist and political
commentator Sherry Jacobus is going to
join us at the bottom of the hour
excited every year I saw a tweet
that she sent out I think it was
actually a reply
where she's talking about
what their plan is
for Trump to take over and I'm talking
about the Maga the Maga Republicans the
actual fascist
that's what they are they're fascist
they're not semi semi-fascists
there there are some Republicans that
are semi-fascist
there are
but they generally see the danger of
Trump I mean Bill Barr for example Bill
Barr is a semi-fascist
at this point you know
and comparatively comparatively
Bill Barr's like he did what with
classified documents
again Trump trump has two airport videos
this weekend two of them
two airplane airport videos
one was from yesterday
from last night he lands in Dulles
and DC it's an International Airport
everyone's like oh [ __ ] is he going to
Russia
is he getting on a plane to Saudi Arabia
I mean you know it's international
airport so generally speaking you're
going to an International Airport you
flying
overseas to another country presumably
but he flew to DC
on a little on a little private jet
because he he can't afford his big one
anymore
he can't he can't afford
his compensation plane you know he's got
to compensate
and I think that maybe maybe that's why
he didn't want anyone know he was coming
to DC because he wouldn't be flying in
on his compensation jet
compensating for you know
you know the Stormy Daniels story
a little shroom
but he flew on a little bitty private
jet it was his it was marked his there
was a video out there on the internet
there was pictures out there on the
internet
just verify that it was yes it was
yesterday
and he gets off the plane
and what appears to be golf attire like
he just came off the golf course which
is not a big surprise I mean to think
that this guy you know probably lays
around in golf clothes
I mean that's all he does he didn't work
he didn't do anything of Interest
there's [ __ ] golf I mean I'm not
saying golf is bad golf sucks but we'll
get into the golf thing but he had golf
shoes on he didn't even have time
to change his shoes which led some
people to believe
that this was not planned
that it was all of a sudden that he had
to hop on this little bitty tiny private
jet
and head to DC because he was in New
Jersey a lot of people thought he was at
Mar-A-Lago he wasn't he said hadn't been
at Mar-A-Lago and the reason why is
because he can't live down there full
time
because they'll kick him out because the
original agreement he made he has to go
away for a while and then come back
Summer's amazing maybe that's the reason
why he's headed to DC maybe there's
documents and some of his properties
around DC and Virginia
so he would go there it seemed as if it
seemed as if because he had his golf
shoes on and he was escorted on the
plane so quickly that he couldn't change
his clothes or his golf shoes
and maybe just maybe it was a medical
emergency it didn't appear to me to be a
medical emergency to be quite honest
with you I mean I think if they would
have had a medical emergency they would
have had him on the out the plane much
quicker into the car much quicker it
would have been much quicker to get away
from the airport to if he was going to
Walter Reed
now again that was some of the first
speculation
there's other video out there of him
heading to the airport to go to
DC in in New Jersey
but there's this America First Nazi
rally that Jared Kushner is going to be
the host of today and what better
what better person than have the orange
Mussolini Jesus himself to appear at the
America first fascist rally
I mean makes sense kind of makes sense
the other thing that might make sense is
maybe just maybe because we know there's
a grand jury
around not just January 6 but the the
grand jury seems to be probing
specifically
specifically
the save America pact and the
legal defense fund which is all [ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] the January 6 select
committee smashed that up with a hammer
like oh you're claiming to collect money
for your legal defense where'd that
money oh there is no legal defense fund
hmm funny you mean it's a fraud hmm
interesting so it seems like there's a
grand jury that has been convened
because Tucker Carlson freaked out he
was freaking out on his show on Fox News
ah there's 50 Trump supporters that are
getting raided they weren't raided
they were issued subpoenas
not rated I mean
you know I mean I guess if someone comes
to your house and hands you a piece of
paper and serves you
that Republicans now think that means
raided
oh my god well I mean when a white
person you know gets handed to speed now
that's rated
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
when you when you break the law when you
commit crimes or Aid in a bed or
or cooperate and conspire with people
who break the law
you generally you generally are witness
Target of interest to Department of
Justice in a criminal probe
with said crime
how is this even [ __ ] surprising I
don't know why anyone would be in a room
close to this son of a [ __ ]
I have no idea why
they would even be in a room close to
this [ __ ]
because you know he's saying all types
of crazy stuff hell he's been saying it
since 2020 after he knew he lost
more news Maggie Haberman
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] listen if you held
on to information at the American people
should have had
to prevent an event like January 6th
and you held it for profit for a book
you're a piece of [ __ ]
you're you're not a journalist
you're a profiteer that's that's what
you are you might as well just stop
calling yourself a journalist and acting
like a journalist and really the the the
journalist outlet that you work for
should say as much too
because apparently Maggie Haberman not
only heard Donald Trump but had
witnessed
Witnesses of AIDS even that even the
[ __ ] guy that brought him his diet
coke
a guy who brought him the [ __ ] Diet
Coke the guy who who had to you know
pour his diet coke in a glass over a
certain amount of ice cubes
you know have a golden tray I'm sure
I'm sure he had to observe it with a
couple package of ketchup I don't know
he eats ketchup on steak maybe he eats
ketchup with Diet Coke I don't know
but he had to come in the Oval Office
and hand him his diet coke when Trump
pushed the diet coke button the diet
coke button guy the delivery guy for the
diet coke button
he was telling that guy
he was telling him hey
should I stay or should I go
I think I'm just gonna stay here
I'm not gonna go I don't think I lost so
that means I don't have to go
he didn't want to leave he wasn't going
to leave is what he said
that's what he was telling people I'm
not gonna leave I won I don't care I
don't care if I really lost doesn't
matter to me
I don't care Biden won got more votes
won the Electoral College
they've certified the State Certified
vote I don't care I'm not going anywhere
but Maggie
manga Haberman as you might call her
decided to hold on to those bits of
information she's a journalist
she's supposed to be reporting
what she sees and what she hears
and she held on to that little tidbit of
information
now almost two years later almost two
years later
for profit
so I think it little it it's a little
you know I don't think we're surprised
by this and I think we're surprised by
the fact that Donald Trump was a whiny
little [ __ ] and he didn't want to leave
the White House
and he thought he thought that he could
just well I'm just not gonna go nowhere
it's not gonna go no I mean he was so
desperate for someone to tell him what
he wanted to hear he was talking to the
Diet Coke guy
trying to take
political
and democracy advice
from the die and I'm not saying maybe
the Diet Coke guy is very informed
maybe he's very astute in these in these
issues
maybe he was a great advisor to Donald
Trump seeing the advisors that the
[ __ ] Cheeto dust mobster had
at the White House
you would think maybe the Diet Coke guy
he might be one of the best advisors I
don't know
but he was asking the Diet Coke guy if
he thought should I just stay here you
know should I just I shouldn't pack my
top secret documents that I want to
steal I don't want to I shouldn't pack
those up I should just hoard them here
in my in my bedroom in the closet here
not down at Mar-A-Lago
I should just stay here and be dictator
and King right Diet Coke guy
that's what is in the book
this morning it's a reporting
so we have a lot of things to talk about
today
airports golf shoes and the Diet Coke
guy
holy actual [ __ ]
this is where we're at folks this is
where we're at we're less than two
months away from the election and these
are the things that we have to
concentrate on and we need to stay
focused here because again with the the
flimsy argument this morning that
somehow
Grandpa Poopypants waved his Big Mac
stained hands over boxes and boxes
of classified documents
that not only did it declassify them
which is just simply not even
Tethered to reality
but somehow that made them his as well
not our property it made it Donald
Trump's property my ass
my ass we I have a I have a I have a
special announcement here
um I don't know we've been doing the
doubtman shirts you guys have loved the
doubt me merch
because I just I always say doubt me
just doubt me doubt me that I don't know
but we've got a new set of merch here it
is the dark Brandon shirts you guys
gotta go check it out
store.joneymichaels.com we got shirts
hoodies stickers and coffee mugs go over
to the Tony michaels.com
store.vdonymichaels.com or you can go to
the Tony michaels.com it'll lead you
there
and get your dark Brandon merch
I love the dark Brandon I actually think
that the reason why Republicans manga
Republicans are so [ __ ] pissed off
about this semi-fascist
is because dark Brandon has risen but
really this is not an alter ego
of of Joe Biden this is just Joe Biden
politicizing what should be politicized
because you know I say here we must
politicize everything everything has to
be politicized
that's how you win elections that's how
you
um
become
uh the governing party
and that is the difference because
there's two things at play in our
country there is government there is
policy you know line items and generally
Democrats in the past have went out and
talked about this line item or this line
item in a bill that doesn't even [ __ ]
exist
and won't even get passed if you let a
bunch of America First Nazis become the
party in power
in our government
not just the federal government States
local governments as well
and then so there's the governed policy
side and then there's the election side
the politics of it all and without the
politics and playing the politics and
winning elections you don't get to
government
and that is what we have to focus on
that is what we must do
and even if airports and golf shoes
makes us aware of the danger of putting
Maga Republicans these America first
fascist not semi-fascists these America
first fascist in power and by God that's
exactly what I'm going to do here on
this show on the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
right here on YouTube Twitter and we
simulcast
from Facebook
every single weekday two hours
so strapping today is going to be a
great episode we have a great guest to
talk
to you about what is important and how
to win
the 2022 midterms but more importantly
what the plan of the America first
fascist is
what their plan is what the Maga
Republicans plan to do because I've been
saying it for a while on this show
doubt me
back to the merch doubt me I've been
saying it for a long time Steve bannon's
been saying it Matt gatz has been saying
it Marjorie Taylor green has been saying
it they want Donald Trump to ascend to a
dictatorship to an autocracy so they can
have their little fascist white
Christian National estate that's what
they want
and they're not gonna quit until they
get it so you can't quit you have to
engage in your democracy you have to
lean into it you must engage in the
ballot and again I don't just mean vote
your neighbors your family your
community members your colleagues your
fellow parishioners the church hell the
people in The Grind at the grocery store
you got to engage with them
they need to know the importance of this
and it can't just be marking ballots you
have to check your registration because
these modern Republicans are trying to
strip you of it
you have to make sure to see if you can
get people registered make phone calls
text message hell write letters send
postcards if you got extra money you
gotta give to these pro-democracy
candidates
and the issue we have right now
in this country is we only have one
party one that is interested in
democracy at all
the other party seems only focused on
autocracy
only focused on taking away your freedom
telling what you can and you cannot do
what religion you can have
who you can marry who you can love how
you raise your children Jesus Christ in
Tennessee they want to marry children in
Florida they want to ban Book Fairs
they're killing women in Texas because
they don't have any rights to their
bodily autonomy there
why have a feeling that this country is
going to reject that notion
because we are on to the America First
fascists the Maga Republicans the people
in Kansas said no
and New York's 19th they said no to my
Republicans we want someone who believes
in democracy the same thing in Alaska
but we cannot just see hope we have to
see what is what is really coming
if they take control of our government
because it's ours it's not it's not some
[ __ ] big government in some weird
building someone with robots in it we
are the government it is us and we get
to decide and while you still had the
opportunity to vote and to use your vote
because they'll take it the [ __ ] away
from you Jesus Christ Lauren bobert
doesn't even know what the 19th
amendment is
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
she is a sitting United States
congresswoman and she has no clue what
the 19th amendment is
not a not a not a [ __ ] idea in her
brain
and that's because she's too worried
about the word Jesus and how that's
going to get her power with a bunch of
fascists
we have to stay focused we have to lean
into it
and we're gonna lean into it today for
two full hours like we do every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter twitch and simulcasting from the
Midas touch Facebook page make sure you
follow us
make sure you follow us on on YouTube
you do not want to miss a video you guys
may have noticed we have a lot of news
Clips a lot of media Clips coming out on
our YouTube page we want you to see
these we do not want you to look away
you have to see exactly what they're
planning they're telling you out loud
Steve Bannon after he was arrested the
other day is telling you out loud what
they want what they want to do and how
they want to do it
so stick around because right after the
break I'm gonna bring on our special
guest today and this is exactly the
topic that we're I'm sure we're going to
get into airports and golf shoes here
but the thing that I wanted to talk to
her about is a tweet she had about this
very issue of what their plan for Donald
Trump is because I really don't think
Donald Trump has a plan
but by God they have a plan and there is
a special plan for him so stick around
we have sherry Jacobus right after this
right after the break don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
I'm gonna come back to the show thanks
for sticking around I have a great guest
for you today
do not disappoint you're into Johnny
Michael podcast
political strategist and political
commentator first time on the show
hopefully not our last
can't wait to talk to her about a tweet
she had the other day Sherry how are you
I'm doing well thanks for having me on
it's good to be here absolutely so you
you said you sent a tweet out I think
you were replying to someone the other
day and you were talking about this plan
and I I've been saying it for months
that the Maga Republicans the America
first fascist is I call them here are
the let's go Brandon Nazis that's what
we call them here we we don't call them
semi-fascists they're full-on fascists
but their plan is to try to win the
house and you think I've been saying it
that I that they want to make Trump the
speaker because a lot of people don't
understand you don't have to be a member
of Congress to be the speaker
um so tell us about what your what your
idea there is and out while I bring up
your Tweet here
well yeah actually I've tweeted it for a
while and it's something that in the
past Tony we never would have put the
stuff out there because people would
have said well that's crazy that's
tinfoil hat conspiracy stuff uh but I
think we're well past a point where we
can say that anything regarding Trump is
tinfoil hat conspiracy stuff because the
worst thing that we can imagine he does
and then he goes even beyond that so we
know that Matt Gates and others have
talked about this uh Republicans win the
house that's why this these midterm
elections are so important Republicans
win the house and they can make Donald
Trump speaker you do not as you said you
do not have to be an elected member of
Congress to be a speaker of the house
and when I tweet this and I'm sure
you've gotten this response from people
when you've noted that this is a plan
for some they're shocked they say that's
not true because you have to be an
elected member of Congress no you don't
uh there are some Democrats I know who
you know want to change this there's
been legislation introduced but it at
this point in time you do not it's never
happened before it's always been an
elected member of Congress but again
with regard to every Everything
regarding Donald Trump we are an in
uncharted waters so yes uh there are
some Republican members of Congress who
plan to win the house and right now if
the election were held today it does
appear Republicans would win although
that Gap is closing uh but they would
make Trump the speaker they can elect
him speaker they would have the votes
McCarthy isn't going to do anything he
will step aside he's not going to
challenge him we know this whatever
Trump wants Trump gets other people who
said well Trump wouldn't do that job
he's too lazy well that didn't stop him
from you know being president for four
years he is lazy he would just Outsource
the job the actual job to somebody else
first and foremost for Donald Trump
right now is he wants in these
investigations to stop he wants to avoid
indictment and the way you do that is to
fire Merit Garland well how do you do
that if you are speaker of the house you
are two heartbeats from the presidency
you are second in line to being
president you are right behind the vice
president
so we already know that the mega
Republicans are violent
insurrectionist election deniers who are
willing to kill they were trying to
assassinate Nancy Pelosi on January 6
and hang Mike Pence we know that um
members of the Secret Service detail
assigned to then Vice president-elect
Kamala Harris on January 6 quote missed
a pipe bomb in their Advanced sweep of
the DNC prior to her visit I don't know
how that happens
so we already know what the mega
insurrectionist violent uh cult are
willing to do they would take care of
those first two heartbeats and Donald
Trump as Speaker would then be installed
as president he can immediately fire
Garland and all of the investigations go
away and if you don't think he's capable
of this then you haven't been paying
attention not just for the past seven
years but his entire adult life so yes I
do think this is the plan for some I
think that what President Biden did in
terms of drawing a clear line between
these radical violent insurrectionists
and perhaps some semi-sane Republicans
who are left you know he's trying to
separate them out and show them the exit
ramp to try and save our democracy so
this is scary stuff but you know we do
have to talk about it openly don't we
well me and Gabe have been talking about
it for a while
um I mean you just can't avoid this
stuff and like just like what you said
because it's dangerous and the reason
why is because there are a few who have
this plan I don't know if this is Donald
Trump's mind it does seem kind of
delusional and far-fetched that that
that that you can make the mechanisms
all work but that is trumpism in and of
itself right I mean the idea that they
could they could just crown him King
with the vice president saying well I
just gonna make anything up that I want
and Trump's the president was
far-fetched and delusional but it didn't
stop them from trying it I guess that's
maybe your point here in this tweet
because I want to I want to read it here
it says so that um so that GOP wins the
house in November and makes Trump's
speaker his Violet manga take care of
the two heartbeats in front of him and
he becomes POTUS fires Garland in the
investigation indictments disappear just
like when sessions Whitaker and Barr or
a g so
Gabe we've talked about this before
mm-hmm
and we've watched as these folks as
Sherry put some insurrectionists like
Lauren bobert Matt Gantz Marjorie Taylor
Greene even Steve Bannon who maybe we'll
get to here in a minute
um
did this but don't you don't you guys
think that this is really
I mean it is wildly delusional don't you
guys think
well yeah I mean I mean absolutely you
you've got a group of people that are so
detached from reality that you know even
from the beginning right there were
there were rumors of there was going to
be a Face-Off situation like the movie
between Biden and Trump there was going
to be
um the reinstallment uh of of trump
which a lot of people online I saw last
night were like oh this is Trump coming
back to DC to become president again
it's like well size were really excited
last night weren't yeah no no totally I
was like I doubt I highly doubt that he
would be in golf attire and that would
be the thing that he'd be walking
through you know into the Oval Office
but you know whatever but it very much
is a group that is detached I mean this
is the same group that was like we're
gonna release the Kraken
event it's gonna happen right these are
all these people that are believing in
some crazy
far-fetched fantasy right whether it's
some Q Anon conspiracy or someone else
believes they interpreted the
constitution of how it was originally
written by the founding fathers years
ago and there's some subtext that no one
else is reading it's crazy but they're
really what it is is it's this
delusional confirmation bias right they
all want it's just like Trump we learned
during the January 6 hearings and even
before that
he would take he would not take no for
an answer he wanted it to be a yes he
wanted his his power to be in stated for
however long he wanted to be president
and he wanted only the people he wanted
yes men and yes women and when he saw
those people that said no or this is
outlandish or crazy he found ways to
remove them or replace them or find
people that would say yes but isn't that
the point here and Sherry that like I
think that's what you're saying is it's
not everyone who's completely off the
rails here it's this Q Anon this
dangerous conspiracy theory
um thread in that Maga Republican party
who will believe just about anything
they're told especially if it's from the
Cheeto dust monster himself don't you
think that's kind of the danger here
well that is the danger here and that's
why President Biden was appealing to the
saner voices in that are left maybe in
the Republican party uh so that they
don't want to be a a part of the crazy
minority when people say oh but you know
half Biden was insulting half of America
no he wasn't it was probably 10 to 30
percent of these people that believe
this however and I think this is
important to remember if Trump wants to
be speaker if the Republicans win they
will let him they will cave to that they
will do it because they are afraid of
this angry base all of these republicans
in Congress caved and now some of them
actually are Republicans but remember in
2016 when trumpers went running for
president establishment Washington uh
and elected officials and party leaders
were not backing Trump they all fell in
line once he became the nominee or or
when he won and since then you know
they've sort of filled up a lot of these
House Seats with mega Republicans and
the others have been forced to Pivot
just to keep their jobs so if Trump
wants the job a speaker
um if Republicans win the house and
Trump wants the job it's his it's his
and I think we just have to accept that
nobody in Congress no Republican in
Congress is going to say no to him
period particularly if they've got you
know the wind at their backs with a win
because of gerrymandering and and other
things uh so you have to look at the
craziest thing I mean think of you know
seven years ago when we thought could
anybody have dreamed that Trump would be
president that any of this could have
happened no we actually thought as I
think Nancy Pelosi and Democrats in
Congress did or hoped and Susan Collins
thought that after the Mueller report
he'd learned his lesson and they didn't
impeach because they were afraid if they
had impeached maybe none of the rest of
this had happened even though the Senate
wouldn't convict so never ever ever
think that Trump or those people who had
see a pinprick of light and they can
push through through violence or
anything else cheating uh don't think
they're not going to do it because every
single step of the way they have every
time
right well and and George will even
pointed out this morning he was on
mourning Joe he's been trending on
Twitter this morning because of his
answer uh his first answer to the
question he kind of well I said it that
he kind of blamed Joe Biden for the
Trump trump and his supporters to be a
bunch of trees in his [ __ ] that
that's how I put it but Mika
um you know she didn't give up on this
thing here she actually re-asked him the
question and he gave sort of an answer
on what you're saying let's listen to
what George Will said about
mygo Republicans being scared of Maga
itself because most Americans are not
tuned into this stuff most Americans are
raising children going on with their
lives who asked you about these
Republicans and what has happened to
them and you John I mean you had some
things to say about but about Joe Biden
and the question is about these
Republican leaders in power right now I
I want to point out
um Miga you know women are going to save
us here because she even has to point
out leaders in power like hello hello
think McFly think like she she's really
pointing out here that you were asked
not about Joe Biden that's not what you
were asked but you were asked about the
Republican leaders that are sycophants
here so let's listen to his answer who
can't seem to quit him who still
to a hugster
and I've got to say George more
disappointing to me friends
family members most of the people who
voted for me in 1994 when I was very
clear about being a small government
conservative very clear about Where I
Stood on issues there is nothing that
Donald Trump is saying that remotely
reflects where you were or where I was I
I I'm trying to figure out why were were
they so open to this huckster who is not
conservative the answer to the why and
amica's question is they're afraid of
their voters
that's the problem it's a very
interesting phenomenon a political party
led by people who are terrified of their
voters if you're terrified of your
voters you can't really like your voters
very much but they are afraid they only
will thing they have to fear is being
primaried from the right
and they do not want to enrage the
intense base
and that makes them ineligible to talk
to the broad middle it's an old Axiom in
American life I actually think he's a
little off here Sherry I think when he
says that he's scared of them because of
being primer and I think that's a bunch
of [ __ ] I think actually some of
these Republicans are terrified because
of physical violence they're being
they're being threatened with physical
violence that's one thing that we're not
seeing some Democrats release some of
these voicemails that they receive at
their Congressional offices at their
homes the text messages the DMS that
they receive you know you know that it's
going it's going to Republicans as well
so you know that's part of the the thing
is the The Fear Factor of violence not
just primaries yeah yeah and I mean I
get those too I just got one before
coming on your show I got an email I
mean it happens all the time I think
it's violence I think it's compromise as
being primary it's it's the whole nine
yards they're they're afraid of it uh
they're afraid of trump they're afraid
of of Putin they're are afraid of the
hardcore Mega radical violent
insurrectionist election denying Maga
and so the only thing they can do is
hope that this message of you know I
think there should be an ad that's that
that if not Democrats but in a line
group put out this is this is remember
the old the old ad uh the old commercial
this isn't your father's old mobile
Oldsmobile they should this isn't your
father's Republican party and they
should show this and they should have
Liz Cheney with her father standing
there and saying this isn't my father's
Republican party and they should show
clips of the violence in the quotes and
and all of the things that this is not
and then end with you know Ron Reagan
with a picture of sitting next to a
picture of his father saying and this
isn't my father's Republican party
because Democrats don't need all of them
they just need some of them in the
midterms and and and
you know Ronald Reagan um was able to
get these Reagan democrats to vote for
him and stick with the GOP for a
generation so Democrats can't castigate
these people that Joe Biden was trying
to gently guide towards the exit ramp of
sanity and saving democracy you can't
castigate them for being Republicans you
can't ask repentance you can't say but
40 years ago whatever you voted for
Reagan and and do all that that's not
how you win elections closer elections
are won or lost in the margins and this
is the margin you have to say join with
us we disagree on a lot we could but do
we agree on saving America and and they
have to be more afraid of Maga taking
over than of Mega
um if that makes any sense because you
have enough republicans in Congress who
secretly probably wish and hope that
Mega would go away that Trump would go
away that as long as it's there pulling
the strings you know and they say JUMP
these guys are going to say how high
well I think you're right
um that you know they you know they wish
that he would go away because then they
have an easier time of the tail wagging
the dog I think that's what George Will
is trying to say here is the tail is
wagging the dog which I think it has
been doing that for a long time I
actually think that's Donald Trump's Mo
he walks into a room and he's like okay
where's the tail who's got the tail and
who's wagging it and then he he becomes
that dog right like any not just a
stadium but any room he walks into and
speaking of him walking
I have to we got it we have to because
he was actually walking last night in
golf shoes I have to go over this
because like we said earlier both sides
are really excited apparently about this
little video that was put out I found it
on Twitter I posted on our account
there's a longer version on YouTube I
linked to the longer version on YouTube
to the person who originally uh shot the
video I think
um in in the Tweet but here is just a
little taste of what happened last night
adoles says the Cheeto dust mobster came
off as itty bitty tiny private plane
one's launch
you see they're getting uh some luggage
out here
and um
it doesn't appear that they're in a
hurry so I I doubted that this was a
medical issue from the very beginning
but you're gonna watch here very soon as
they're climbing in to get the luggage
into the other vehicle
you're gonna watch Donald Trump exit
here here he is it looks like he has a
Maga hat in his hand and there they are
there they are Sherry there's the white
shoes there's the white shoes before he
gets into the into the van now a lot of
people were speculating last night all
over the place some were saying oh he's
being arrested he's in handcuffs which
he wasn't
um some were saying maybe he's coming to
testify before a grand jury maybe he's
being charged and he's gonna
self-surrender for an arrest maybe maybe
he's just needs more Big Macs than the
McDonald's in the DC area has a lot
better Big Mac than the one over in New
Jersey
um you actually said that Jared Kushner
has this America first fascist rally
that they're doing today maybe that's
where he was going to show up some are
saying maybe that's what it is what
what's your take and why does this
matter that he showed up unannounced no
Fanfare in his golf attire it seems like
he hopped on the plane very fast and and
it was unplanned and what's your day
going well initially it seemed like it
might be a medical issue not enough
emergency of emergency to go to an
emergency room but certainly to get him
um to Walter Reed relatively quickly and
that's why he was still you know had his
golf shoes on I don't think he was
coming uh to this area I'm in the DC
area I don't think he's here to golf the
weather report was bad and it would have
been announced and maybe there'd be
people with him so it could be if he
does go to the Jared Kushner speech
Maggie Haberman claims that he wasn't
and of course we know that she is the
Trump Whisperer for money for profit
yeah yeah and
um so but if he does go there or if
there are people at that event and if
there is a message that he needs to
deliver personally or documents that
need to be exchanged uh in person
um he would do it even if it's to see
his son-in-law in a different Forum you
know or he could be moving documents
around from his DC Area Properties
Maryland Virginia but it does seem to be
related to something like that this was
it seemed like a relatively impromptu
trip or he he could be secretly
surrendering I mean all of the things
that people are speculating
um could be true but I think what's
important is to note that first of all
nothing is coming out of trump world uh
to explain or deny anything his family
doesn't seem to know he hasn't been on
Truth social so there's something
different going on and what's
interesting is notice all of it seems
like it's really bad for him it's all
bad news and the fact that we don't even
blink an eye that he could be selling
documents hiding documents destroying
documents meeting with people to deliver
secret information
having a serious medical issue I mean
when it comes to Trump again as we were
discussing earlier nothing is too
outrageous or tin foil it's not a
tinfoil hat conspiracy think like a
criminal
get in his big
ugly white golf shoes and think if
you're in Trump's position and you're in
this much trouble what are all the
possible things that you will try to do
and then assume he will try to do them
right well I think between the time he
was on the blame and got in the car that
was probably the only time in the last
few hours that he wasn't climbing
um here is um here's the book cover for
Maggie hamrin's new book for profit on
the backs of the American people I'm not
gonna play the thing but in in the book
she claims that he is you know again
he's predictably unpredictable like
you're saying and of course he would
have done the delusional thing to think
he could just I'm just not gonna pack my
[ __ ] I'm just not gonna pack my [ __ ] not
go anywhere and I'll live in the White
House and be the president of the United
States
um what do you make of the Diet Coke guy
as his advisor for why he should stay
and then I want to move on to another
footage of air airport airport footage
that happened a few months ago when you
because you brought up the documents but
yeah but what what do you make of this
book a Maggie uh first of all you Maggie
writing these books for profit this is
her second one in very short order and
holding on to this information that it
that could have uh saved us from January
6th could have saved lives and she's
holding on to this information
um when reporters do that I have a
couple questions first of all the source
is for the books what are they getting
in return for being sources for her
for-profit book and why are her
employers allowing her to do this
um I think that she could be I think she
should be sued for it for review I think
any reporter should be and I think their
employers are the ones that should do it
as long as you are a reporter
um and any information you get uh
belongs to your employer employee if
you're an employee
um this information belongs to your
employer uh if you are freelancing out
there doing this stuff for a book you
should no longer be uh protected under
the what how the Press is protected you
know they're allowed to to not reveal
their sources
um this is sleazy uh it happens too
often and we've seen it where when lives
are at stake so uh if Maggie Haberman
had information in advance
um uh like this it could have saved us
from um some of the the problems on on
January 6 had she reported it as a New
York Times Reporter uh but this
for-profit stuff with reporters holding
on to information is not going to change
in terms of his advisors I mean look at
the people he's hired that he relied on
in the past so Diet Coke guy doesn't
matter I mean uh he hired Kaylee mcinany
as his press secretary the job that
Marlon Fitzwater had you know and uh and
you know really incredible talented
people like you know Mike McCurry and
Kaylee macanonias exactly zero political
experience prior to Jeff at CNN Trump's
little buddy creating her out of whole
cloth and building her up for Trump so
he could make her this person behind the
podium
um doing and saying things that no
self-respecting actual political
strategist press secretary I've been a
press secretary would ever do so Trump
has a long history of elevating
unqualified
and unethical people to positions they
could never get within a mile of I'm
going to put kellyanne Conway in that in
that category kellyanne had been a
poster and a TV pundit but had never
ever worked for an elected official and
you know and it showed so yeah she
didn't like Trump either she didn't read
it either well she was for sale and so
was her husband you know George
flip-flop back and forth you know
several times uh but uh so Trump didn't
mind if you let loose here on the
journey yeah that's fine
so he hires these people who will do
anything
um and they also don't understand the
job they really think that their job is
to take orders from him to tell him what
he wants to hear and to they don't even
know where the guard rails are
um and so those guard rails are already
down and he has a long long history of
doing this and it's very very dangerous
believe it or not
um it really is a profession those of us
who have done it for decades you know to
be a political strategist
um
do you think Maggie Haberman uh because
me and Gabe have Gabe we talked about
this several times do you think that
Maggie Haberman is in some sorts in some
way of political strategist where she
frames the you know she's so close to
Trump where she frames some of these
stories and it appears sometimes she's
she's trying to be a journalist but it
appears at other times that it's only in
the favor of trump and maybe herself but
yeah isn't that in that the story of
trumpism and Trump World it's access
journalism and he rewards it just like
it was alarming to me when he basically
was handed the Rings to CNN in 2015 and
2016 and he was calling the shots and
when he was doing that
um at Fox News I mean I I had been in
the business for a long time I'd been on
TV thousands of times of the course of
20 years I worked on Capitol Hill I was
a party spokesperson I you know ran
campaigns did the whole nine yards uh
but and you always expect certain media
they will once the primaries are over
and you have your nominees you knew that
fox was going to lean right you knew
that MSNBC would lean left you knew that
CNN would try to you know be in the
middle I had never seen this in a
primary when there were you know 15 16
candidates to see
these TV networks just capitulate and do
his bidding and it was chilling and I
was living in New York at time and I
would be in the Fox Studios you know a
couple times a week and I'm seeing this
happen and it was just so I kind of had
a little bit of an advance notice of you
know my personal experience with Trump
to know what the rest of the country now
knows which is why I don't think
anything is so far-fetched in such a
conspiracy you know tinfoil hat uh
possibility with Trump because I've
known it for seven years
um and it's alarming but again back to
your point about the people that he
believes I mean he installed his
daughter and son-in-law in positions and
they couldn't even get security
clearances because they were they were
so uh so bad so we we've we've seen this
we've seen you know the people that he's
installed and his his acting
um you know acting AG like Matt Whitaker
and other people who probably would have
some real problems again making it
through Senate confirmation so he's like
ah I'll just make them acting and that's
how he gets around it again he's knocked
down all the guard rails and
unfortunately too many people have
allowed them and Maggie Haberman is one
of them
something you bring up yeah I was going
to say something you bring up totally
agree with and I think Tony does as well
like the the my biggest uh
uh frustration or pet peeve or whatever
you want to call it I mean is you've got
you know Stephanie Grisham Bill Barr uh
Maggie Haberman Bob Woodward these are
all people who had
very pivotal crucial information
especially Bob Woodward when we're
talking the covid uh pandemic these are
people who had access when it was when
it happened to know that either there
was intentional line there was
misinformation or there was a
distraction method happening
and then it wasn't until you know 18
months later when they said hey I've got
this book coming out and it really is
this profit over people where it's like
the you know what is the What is the the
betterment or well-being of the U.S
American citizens and to those people
they say I'd rather take the sign-in
bonus and the deal with the publisher to
hold on to that juicy gossip or whatever
it is that put our lives or our country
at stake and say I'd rather just take
that instead of actually do my job as a
reporter or a journalist or whatever it
might be to actually report on these
things as they happen so we're aware of
it and we can prevent
a much more catastrophic problem from
occurring and I think that you know
again to your other point about like who
he actually hires we see right now there
is no legitimate high-powered attorney
that is willing to take on this case you
know not willing to touch it with like a
hundred foot pole right now he's got
these TV lawyers that are throwing them
crazy legal theories and accusations I
think they even just responded to the
motion yesterday or today as to the 100
classified documents and it really is
this thing of trump says I need to get
away with this and they're like well I
guess we'll just throw whatever at the
wall and see what sticks
because you don't want to say no we have
to say yes because you know I and I also
don't know
why these people agree to it whether
it's Fame because we know they're not
going to get paid at the end of the day
so you know really is that desire of
building yourself or you know I mean we
got James trustee who's who was hired
from seeing him on Fox news on TV right
these are we literally have these
lawyers who have no experience or some
of them do but not all of them and this
team is like ragtag team of Misfits that
in the end is like there isn't going to
be this Underdog Story it really is a
team of [ __ ] they're gonna
you know mess it up well you don't want
anything to get away with it and they
get away with it yeah with it um I but
focusing on them I think we have to
focus on us we have to focus on our
media that props these people up who
says it's okay uh you know like people
at CNN if you're a CNN contributor you
can't speak out against Maggie Hagerman
because guess what she's also a CNN
contributor um that's why I didn't play
the piece for CNN I put it out there on
on Twitter so that everyone can see it
you should go watch the the full version
of it but they do they they just act
like ah no big deal you know it's great
that she's putting this information out
today kind of thing yeah yeah and so you
know we see this over and over again but
we have to we should focus on us why are
we allowing this why are we buying the
books uh why are we not you know
speaking out uh a lot like I mean you
see a lot of people speaking out against
Maggie Haberman but again you see I also
see a lot of blue check marks if they're
even at other networks they're very very
careful to speak out against one one of
their own so to speak and in some cases
I know at CNN you know they are
specifically told you cannot criticize
uh somebody else who's on the network
well so great so that means when CNN
hired uh Corey Lewandowski or Kaylee
mcinany with zero experience or they
have you know Michael Caputo on who is
responsible for Untold I don't know how
many uh coveted deaths when he was at
HHS you know trying to infect as many of
us as possible and Jimmy around and
manipulate the CBC kova data uh once the
executives the TV Executives decide to
put these people on and treat them as
respected professional analysts they
have to treat them as colleagues uh it's
it's all over uh Scotty Nell Hughes was
hired at CNN remember her and she went
on to work for Russia today and she was
the one that was suing Fox News because
she was having the affair and she's
married she's having the affair with
Charles Payne who was also married and
she was suing him because it was well
known that if you have an affair with
these guys you get a contract and she
didn't get a contract so she was
literally suing because she had sex with
him but she didn't get a Fox News
contract so why I mean that's how messed
up things are
um you know and and CNN hired her as a
political analyst or political
contributor uh so you know we see this
over and over and over again uh so and
part of it is us that we defend this uh
that these people are propped up who
shouldn't be
um you know kellyanne was a known
repeated liar and she was being put on
TV all the time and then has this you
know top book on the New York Times
bestseller list so you know we can blame
well we should look at the people who
are being hired and what they're getting
away with what their bosses or letting
them get away with but we allow it they
they they don't they can't do this
without you know the public going yeah
okay
well you know you everyone's you're
bringing up lawyers and [ __ ] and
all these people around Trump who just
capitulate and I want to show you a
bunch of people who either capitulate or
didn't know what the hell was in these
boxes
um there is another piece of airport
footage that kind of get uh swept under
the rug from the golf shoes the golf
shoes to kind of uh overshadowed this
piece where there seemed to be cartons
As Trump put them
um eight of them I think is the count
here and I actually have a video that
counts them here on the screen of these
boxes that were taken and I believe this
is back in May uh I think it's May 8th
they reported it on May 9th and am I
correct in that game yeah because May
6th was the Nara uh letter that was like
Hey the National Archives where they
were like hey everyone our [ __ ] back and
they're like we don't have it and then
May 9th I believe it was when this
happened and so you're like three days
later they're moving on May 8th and I
think it was reported on me oh okay yeah
so within two or three days there was
right yeah this this happened
so let's play this and then we'll talk
about the the lead up to this and then
the aftermath and then the lead up to
today there's a motion
um because we're running out of time
here but I want to show this
there's one box
oh there's two three four oh man these
cartons are heavy
they're heavy
some suitcase oh it's five and six boxes
there
we're gonna get um seven and eight
there's seven and eight I believe
again a lot of stuff going into the
plane there's seven and eight
so these being loaded in
um and you know I can show Donald Trump
going into the plane but I mean
obviously he does now this in the lead
up to this because like Gabe said the
National Archives was like hey we need
our [ __ ] back this is all missing and
he's like no it's my stuff and they're
like no no it isn't it's our stuff and
and this idea that somehow it's a
storage issue and they just wanted to
keep it secure no they knew he needed to
keep it secure because it was top secret
classified stuff and Nara was freaked
out they were freaked out that this guy
took this stuff and they're like you
need to keep it secure more secure than
mar-lago we need that back and it got to
a point where and again this is the
capitulation that people do with this
[ __ ] buffoon is they capitulate
capitulate capitulate until they get to
a moment where like okay we just got to
get the Department of Justice involved
in this to go down there and get this
[ __ ] this is this could be criminal you
know Nara is not a it's not a criminal
investigative body they are Librarians
literally they are Librarians trying to
make sure they archive our history our
country's history is what this is this
is going to be a part of our history one
of these days and this idiot was taking
him down and storing them in the pool
house down at Mar-A-Lago now
um this morning they filed a motion uh
another I'm rubber your glue type uh
defense here where it's like no they're
his and prove prove that they're
classified what have you read this
decision Sherry what do you make of this
uh this motion this morning that they're
fine well I've I've read sort of the
overview of some of this stuff what
they're looking at first and foremost I
think is
um this this part of the law that says
if you are caught with this material and
you're mishandling this stuff
um then basically you can't run for
office again you can't hold office so
that's the first thing which I think uh
hopefully Merrick Garland is doing
something about you know you do triage
first retrieve the documents secondly
make sure this guy can't run for office
again so if he broke those laws
um that would apply so I think his
lawyers are trying to make it seem as
though it wasn't government material it
was his so that takes care of that layer
of problems for him but he's also
obstructing justice and in an affidavit
filed I guess by the FBI within the last
couple weeks they note that they have
video evidence that he was moving and
hiding this material to obstruct justice
so that's what this video is I initially
thought it was maybe a security video
that they got at Mar-A-Lago but I think
it's probably the video that you just
showed because then I remember hearing
right after it happened
um right after the raid shortly
thereafter the FBI agents were alarmed
at some video evidence that they had so
we've been hearing this so what this
does is it puts Trump in Jeopardy
legally on a number of different issues
so my guess is that they're trying to
make it seem like well he that law
doesn't apply to him where he can't run
because he got caught with this stuff
taking it removing it mishandling it
because if they can make the case that
it was his instead of belonging to the
government that eliminates that problem
I I think I think you're right that it's
that um this is more evidence like these
motions that they're filing and because
I think he's actually just doing what
Trump does is delay here like he's not
really he doesn't really have any kind
of defense or throwing everything up
against the wall to see what sticks yeah
I mean there's no spaghetti monster yeah
there's also like you say the delay
tactic which he's done with past vendors
contractors whoever might be because his
goal is list I've got this money
somewhere that I can use to uh to
litigate as long as I want but the
government's like all right bet let's
see how long you can last because the
government you know you endless resource
of and it's a criminal investigation
right exactly and the government's like
look we've got a big budget we can keep
going with this
yeah but here's here's the problem and
this is this is where it shows that
Trump is still pulling the strings on
everything because still controlling the
timeline in the agenda he obstructed
Justice for months and months and months
and months and months bumping us up to
this point where now we're in that
magical zone of the midterm elections
and this supposed you know the doj
policy not law but policy where they
won't indict or even really um uh
robustly investigate of 60 days or 90
days whatever before an election now
Trump isn't on the ballot and since it
was Trump jerking everybody's chain all
these months uh and not returning the
documents purposely delaying by
obstructing justice now he's protected
by that doj policy it's insane uh he's
the one that got us to this point where
we are in that zone before uh midterm
election but he is not on the ballot so
doj uh Merrick Garland you know honoring
that somehow is is is just insane it's
beyond comprehension uh that Trump is
being allowed to get away with this I
mean we're looking at this video
watching this stuff it's like he's
breaking the law he is a danger he
should not be running loose so he's
probably blackmailing the government
saying hey I'm going to release these
secrets in these secrets I got more and
it's all going to come out if you arrest
me you know who who knows there's
there's we're either letting him go
because he's been indicted on nothing uh
and Trump is above the law or there's a
lot going on behind the scenes that even
the really smart people can't figure out
is one or the other at this point
um but it's alarming that he is roaming
free
well I I think you're I think you're
right and I appreciate you uh joining us
Sherry and hopefully
um there are more signs and more
evidence that the doj is moving on him
like a like a [ __ ] and and grabbing him
by the top secret documents because I
actually believe that that is the case
that is to be made very quickly here
because um it's kind of black and white
you know not to give a pun for documents
but it it is kind of written in black
and white there exactly what this is and
and you know they keep saying the
presidential
um records act they keep bringing that
up as if that's it's going to say yeah I
mean James trust he's throwing out this
article too which is like that is not at
all what Article 2 gives you would you
would you interest unlimited power
Cherry would you trust a lawyer that you
saw on TV who's whose character name is
Trusty trustee Jim trusty trust me I'm
Jim trustee would you would you believe
this and and before we go he's the only
anything you want before we go uh well
okay I have a podcast and I started up
restart it up again after a 15 month
hate is due to cancer
um but my podcast is on patreon and his
politics with Sherry Jacobus I hope
you'll tune in my uh follow me on
Twitter at Sherry Jacobus
c-h-e-r-i-j-a-c-o-b-u-s and my website
is Sherry jacobus.com
what give us one last take on trustee
there what do you think you know he
can't he can't well no uh just because
he took the job he can't pick his last
name but it's my understanding that he
is the is the only lawyer in a very long
time that actually has you know some
chops uh so
um you know some legal chops um ethical
chops who knows well it sounds like the
attorneys are hiring attorneys because
Christine Obama said they had to seek
which I would be curious to know who's
who is her attorney at this point like
who's willing to take the case that she
might have obstructed or been involved
with uh the mishandling his documents
I'm just like we'll get to the bottom of
it I'm sure we get it Sherry thanks for
joining us don't be you come back please
come back soon anytime you want to talk
um we are open to any kind of talk here
on the Tony Michaels podcast we welcome
all pro-democracy speech here so thank
you for joining us and everyone stick
around we're gonna go to the [ __ ] list
Roundup we're gonna serve the Tweety
tweets and journey dreams we get a lot
of footage to get to right after this
break don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after these messages thank
you Sherry
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
oh what a Monday
[Music]
airport stall shooting top secret
agumans
apparently the queen is being coated
around UK I don't know I I'm I'm
honestly uh I don't know how well I gave
I I know it's just gonna probably piss
some people off that like the monarchy
and the pop and Circumstance of it all
but how long do they tote around the
dead body of the queen before they
finally bury her is it is that a is
there like a the length of time she was
alive
holy [ __ ] we got a while to go I mean I
I we've talked about this before when it
happened because the news broke right we
were on the show that uh Queen Elizabeth
II who is the longest serving Monarch
um in on the throne yeah that England
has ever seen of course she was under
like 456 years or something like that
yeah well yeah yeah I mean give or take
a couple years you know again I we are
not used to monarchy here like we don't
have Kings or Queens I mean some people
think we should uh the Mongol
Republicans definitely want an autocracy
um you know they definitely want a
dictatorship but you know the the
the Queen of England was a little
different but you know you want to have
a fun fact I learned the other day oh
what what yeah go ahead yeah so Queen
Elizabeth had two severely disabled
first cousins who were publicly
pronounced dead in 1940 and 1961.
but they actually both lived in a care
home with no visits or support from the
royal family until their actual deaths
in 1986 and 2014. what do you mean they
hid these people yeah Jesus Christ the
family never sent the girls a birthday
or Christmas gift or card and when uh
and when one died in 1986 none of the
family attended the funeral her grave
was marked with plastic tags and a
serial number until her existence was
revealed in the media after which the
family added a gravestone
uh and then the women received no money
from the family other than 125 pounds
paid to their Hospital each year
like that is when people are like oh my
God the the the queen blah blah and I'm
just like look there's a reason one we
tried to leave and go to it and start a
new country there's a reason why we had
a revolutionary war there's a reason why
we as America
did not want a monarchy right but also
that type of even though as the queen
there's no kind of like you know
Parliament is the Once making the laws
and making the policy yeah because it
was a different time during the
Revolutionary War right War than when
she took over after the second but even
even right now this rule of or not rule
but this kind of influence of the
monarchy I think is you know I saw an
interview on CNN from one woman in the
UK and she was like yeah I will admit it
is unfortunate to have any family member
that is sick in the hospital
however I don't like the queen like I
just don't care for too much and I think
you know it's it's interesting to see
more and more of that come out
um because I think that was a discussion
that was over this weekend which is like
oh would they get rid of the monarchy
you know would they kind of dissolve it
and yeah well because a lot of people
are pissed off that you know about
Charles but I mean that's just the way
it works that's the shitty I that's the
shitty problem with monarchies is you
don't get a [ __ ] Choice yeah like you
don't get to choose you don't that that
it is what it is and right Wingers are
pissed off because he believes that
climate change exists and of course the
left is pissed off because he's a
[ __ ] King I mean but really you know
to give Queen Elizabeth her do even even
though there is a lot of weird nasty
vile stuff like
um the racism pointed at Meghan Markle
yeah or even the treatment of Princess
Diana you know right well right exactly
well and even at the what you're talking
about with the family members she was
very diplomatic she was a very good
Diplomat and I believe that's what
probably keeps the monarchy going she
was able to manage
um to keep the monarchy as the head of
state or the the face of the UK now
rather Charles and William will be able
to do that I guess only time will tell
but you know a lot of people in the
world are not especially um who had to
suffer the British colonialism
um don't necessarily
have a great taste in their mouth about
it but you know I mean I've got a you
know I was I was on set this weekend and
I was working with a buddy who's you
know who's Indian in his family
obviously you know has experienced it
both ways the rule the rule of
colonialism right and so he was like
yeah I could care less like yeah [ __ ]
him right yeah I mean he really was like
I mean obviously obviously anyone who
has been at the heart end of the Stick
of British colonialism is not going to
like the crown right they're just not it
doesn't matter who it is really yeah I
mean no matter how diplomatic they may
seem
um of course they say Charles is not as
Diplomat I don't know a lot about them I
don't know you know I mean prince Andrew
is also a creep if there wasn't anything
there was a video that came out this
weekend of him like when they were there
was trending is that what he's trending
yeah probably it's the video of him
would I who I believe might be his
daughter don't quote me on that but
there he goes down the back and then
like kind of touches the butt and then
goes down the leg so like Donald Trump
manga type stuff yeah yeah yeah it's
it's pretty weird I mean we already know
obviously prince Andrew is a creep but
this was just like caught on camera and
it went from the back I think that's the
that's what's trending I think that's
what's trending so let's do this let's
get to the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends because I got not just the Andrew
video to show you that I didn't know
about here I'm just finding this out
breaking news Gabe pointed this out to
me
um but we got a lot of other video to
get to and we do not have a lot of time
so let's do this let's go to the [ __ ]
let's round up let's surf the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
of all the Tweety tweets and journey
drones you know I think I think one
there's a bunch of people heckling uh
prince Andrew but I think this is the
video that you were talking about here
it's got like 2.4 million views here is
this the one is this the one you're
talking about that is probably it's not
a high quality one but yeah yeah see we
can find a better one
um it looks like he may be trending
though because of another video of some
hecklers heckling him and this is one
thing they do not like
um
the monarchy does not like to be heckled
apparently there's been several people
yanked out of these crowds as the
Queen's body was being
um you know ceremonially moved around
the UK um but here is here's apparently
people uh being beaten by police as they
Heckle prince Andrew let's listen
[Music]
[Laughter]
I I love the accent because it really
feels like a long and done nothing wrong
I mean that really makes makes me feel
like he probably didn't do anything
wrong here is a here's another video of
them detaining him
um
here we go let's let's play this here
here's another video of them detaining
him
you're allowed to commit
ment just pointing it out just being
honest it's uh this isn't this isn't
crazy new stuff look if you CR if you
committed a crime a sexual crime against
someone
's gonna probably point it out so yeah
yeah and also it's like if you did that
then you should you know there are
consequences to the actions that you
take so here is um here's a Tic Tac
video Someone uh recording their TV
let's see if we can we can see the where
you're saying he grabs her but yeah just
watch just watch
oh
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know
a little weird oh yeah
they're they're you you decide I don't
know seems a little weird to to keep
your hand there that long yeah I don't
know I don't know I mean I mean there is
so much more there is so much more
there's so much more
I'm it it is not surprising that that
would be something that he would
probably do considering his but it's
it's not necessarily the Trump Ivanka
Pat because we watch Trump Like Pat yeah
right yeah yeah I mean why couldn't he
hugs her and he's like yeah you know and
it's that's [ __ ] weird
um
whew we just got so much Red Lobster's
trending now game what the hell is Red
Lobster turning for
people discuss oh my god oh what's your
favorite now but we have we have I just
want to when when people ask these
questions on Twitter they're like hey
can you guess who this is
like a picture of someone yeah it's like
can you guess who this actress or the
celebrity is Twitter ruins it because
Twitter then has the person's name
on what the trend is and then it quotes
in or it embeds in the Tweet of like do
you know who this is and it's like well
that you just ruined the game for me
because now you told me what the answer
was right because you see the name you
click on it and then it's like who is it
you don't think you didn't have to click
on it you just get the preview where it
says Red Lobster and this seems to be
the yep yeah they don't understand so
people don't understand why Red Lobster
probably is still in business why what's
wrong with Red Lobster I've never been
to a Red Lobster what yeah never been oh
my God what the hell what about what
about Olive Garden you've never been in
oh dude family of course
well I mean you know you know dark red
zones
Olive Garden and red light you know the
cheddar bay biscuits come on man I mean
I'm I'm not one to turn down some
[ __ ] Olive Garden breadsticks but Red
Lobsters Cheddar Bay Biscuits Jesus
Christ I mean maybe you know what if you
come to La we'll go to a Red Lobster
I'm not gonna go all the way to LA to go
to a Red Lobster that's the deal right
down the street that's the deal
okay it's gonna be you come here you
come here and we'll go to the
I would rather go to a coastal Red
Lobster than one in the midwest oh well
you know they have fresh Lobster
sometimes swimming around in the tank uh
George Will is trending this morning
um for his horrible take
um on a question that he was asked on
MSNBC this morning morning Joe I played
this I played for Sherry the the second
time around when Mika's like hey you
didn't answer the [ __ ] question right
answer the question but this is the
original reason why he was trending and
why people were pissed off at him so I
want to play I want to play that let's
listen like what what was it about our
party what was it about the conservative
movement that led so many this direction
uh and and how could they have been
so uh so open to uh huckster like Donald
Trump
there's a small number of Americans who
only feel alive when they're angry
okay I agree with that point that he's
making there that that a small and and
again it's a large number of people but
it's a small percentage in comparison to
the rest of the country yeah and
sometimes it's not always right-wing but
right now it's it's it is the right wing
like they are completely angry because
they have this delusion of what is real
and they're not Tethered to reality but
watch who he blames it on Gabe why don't
you he blames it on it's it's hilarious
uh I don't think most Americans are
angry I think they're exhausted and they
are they are longing for a restoration
of normality Joe Biden's great unforced
error
was not to realize this what what wait a
second wait a second so the people who
are angry
are angry it's because of Joe Biden's
unforced Eric get the [ __ ] out of here
with this nonsense I'm not even gonna
play the rest of it this is ridiculous
this is this crybaby calling Republican
semi-precious [ __ ] well he's lying about
it the main issue I have here is the
fact that you know he's taught well one
is like yeah sure people are gonna feel
more alive when they're angry I think
that's just naturally like when you
emote anger right just like happiness
like when you're on two ends of the
spectrum people typically feel more
alive when you're somewhere in the
middle like oh you know it's whatever
like you know it's it's kind of benign
so I think that's like a like a site
kind of 101 analysis right it would be
the same thing if it's like hey people
who are either very elated or excited or
joyful about something or very angry and
pissed off are the only people that are
going to write reviews about a
restaurant or a business that's why one
you know when you see this stuff on Yelp
or whatever the review might be
it's only going to be those extremes
it's either happy or mad right or upset
or whatever it might be so when he says
oh well yeah I think people that are
anger or you know A Little More Alive
well [ __ ] of course they are but I
think it's not just a it's not just it
you know I think what do you say
frustration or whatever he said right
I yes I think I would agree there there
are people that I said they're tired he
said I'm very tired exhausted right I
mean we are exhausted to have to
continue to listen to you [ __ ] idiots
right capitulate to a Goddamn treasonous
piece of [ __ ] I mean how is that to get
exhausting well no totally I mean if you
go through four to five years of hearing
this Insanity of people committing these
crimes getting away with these crimes
within the Trump Administration
violating the Hatch Act nothing being
done doing this a lot of people I talk
to people every day where i'm chatting
with them you know on Twitter or or like
Instagram or texting friends and there
is this topic that comes up a lot which
is like will this even matter like oh
well the documents even do anything well
he even go to jail will he even get like
a slap on the rest or is it gonna be
something like oh he just can't run in
20 he just can never run again and that
is the punishment and I feel like yeah a
lot of people are exhausted because
they're tired of [ __ ] not happening to
people who do bad things right because
because you know and so when they when
he says like oh well it's Joe Biden's
fault for not realizing no [ __ ] Joe
Biden and the Democratic like you know
uh uh the group are are working to in
repairing and improving the things that
were broken right uh the economy
infrastructure uh investing in
technology with a chips act right uh
helping to fund school lunches and uh
and education like these are all things
that should inherently be like no
[ __ ] duh but things that we either
ignored or we cut away in the previous
administration and so now what we're
doing under the Biden Administration is
trying to fix that [ __ ] because we're
already like we see those things
crumbling along the way and we're trying
to repair them as well but we're also
fighting you know a senate that's pretty
much 50 50 split or 4852 split for the
the Republicans but Joe Biden is right
now in the last two months or so has
been doing a great job of fixing those
things and identifying that that
exhaustion and that frustration and that
you know that that tired feeling to say
look we are we will become that America
again that we all knew we had the
potential of becoming and so when I hear
[ __ ] like this I think it's
right well here's the thing is that is
that I think you're right Joe Biden is
pointing out that exhaustion and the the
absolute
[ __ ] just there's Americans are sick
and tired of having to capitulate to
lies and delusion and [ __ ] they
don't want to hear about him anymore
they just like look just [ __ ] hold
him accountable and let's move the [ __ ]
on and I think Joe Biden is tapping into
that and they're scared of dark Brandon
speaking of dark branded Gabe we got
some dark Brandon whoa dark Brandon
merch damn go to store.the
tonymichaels.com
God damn you can get your dark Brandon
t-shirts hoodies those are pretty cool
man monks that's a pretty cool design
that's a pretty cool design we made it
custom just for you we made it custom
just for you for your dark Brandon
t-shirts hoodies stickers coffee mug so
go to store.tonymichaels.com
and get your dark Brandon merch don't
forget to go pick up some of that dark
brand of merch but here's the thing even
on Fox News they're still whining and
crying about the alter ego dark Brandon
of Joe Biden like they call this
semi-fascists I mean even this morning
here is on this morning here it is these
two the two Fox fascists here did and
then they don't even know what antifa is
it's beautiful the Chiron right now
before I even see this clip I know where
the well I have an idea where it's going
but also just the Chiron VP Harris
refuses to Define semi-fascists like do
we even need to Define what a
semi-fascist is well to them they need
it because they can't read a [ __ ]
dictionary apparently
um we ignored you know World War II you
know all of these things like we were we
were as America we were anti-fascists we
are anti-fascists so when it's like hey
look this group is fascist or they're
semi-fascist you should probably go ding
ding those guys are bad guys right we
fought those bad guys the people who
stormed the beach of Omaha
in Normandy those were anti-fascists
yeah they were anti-fascist watch
because they don't know what antifa is
they they just don't know well listen
but if they are anti
semi-fascists
okay okay if a game if they're anti not
anti-fascist but anti-semitis yeah let's
see which is how they see more than half
the country now because Democrats are
looking up and saying look we just want
lower prices
they sure are looking up at the
semi-fashions and go why are you [ __ ]
taking away our rights right and wanting
to take away Book Fairs and wanting to
marry our children in Tennessee and
you're wanting to make sure women can't
get medical procedures that would save
their [ __ ] life yeah we just want to
concentrate on real [ __ ] not your
[ __ ] culture wars that's exactly what
they're doing dummy they always run face
first into it babe face first and do it
literalism 1.99 gas
um are they pro-antifa because they've
been rather violent I mean yeah yeah we
are pro-antifa we are
anti-fascist yeah like they're like oh
don't call me a fascist that's a bad
word but you're an anti-fascist right
you piece of [ __ ] you're against fascism
like what are you talking about like
they can't even Square the circle it is
[ __ ] hilarious well it's it's also
like they're like oh these anti-fascists
are violent
uh let's back up here okay let's go to a
date that was just last year January 6th
right the idea that
we're the violent ones right especially
when you look into like the 20. Gabe
Gabe when 2016 happened there were a ton
of antifa that stormed every single
Capital they had fake electors that they
tried to slate they [ __ ] were calling
Barack Obama the sitting president was
calling State officials to try to get
them to overturn elections they were
trying to they were sending out their
[ __ ] TV attorneys their [ __ ]
ambulance Chaser attorneys to State
officials to try to get them to do
anything they could to steal the
election and when it wasn't stolen and
Diva surged the capital and they [ __ ] on
the walls they threatened to kill the
speaker and hang the bites wait that
doesn't sound right that one 2016 what
year was that those those 20
21. oh oh so you're saying you're saying
the anti-fascists are only violent when
they have to stop the violent fascist
like in the second but even the
anti-fascists that are violent in that
on that day is like oh they're law
enforcement right what happened well
guys guys what happened to back in the
blue baby well you guys are all about
those people yeah they don't yeah
they're they're the anti-fascists you
know they're anti I only she's like
antifa like oh this clip gets better
it's better better it gets better with
the antifa stuff listen I I had to
listen to it a few times and I posted
the clip and I still don't know what the
[ __ ] she's saying here listen these are
fair things that you can ask if you can
get one of them to sit down again
preferably the United States President
your quick last thought what yeah they
of course won't ever ask those questions
I mean remember we still have members of
the Democrat Party that pretend antifa
doesn't exist well they're still but
they're using the word
it's just a belief I don't like [ __ ]
fascism oh my God it's
stands for
what what that's the part where I
couldn't listen to what she says on the
end of antiva listen that's what that
yeah
stands for the what the f a
does she know what the fa stands for she
said that's what the fa stands for
fascist yeah yeah feel them writing
that's what that yeah
stands for
I still don't get her Point here I think
she's trying to I don't I mean I think
she's just trying to break it down and
say like what like all of a sudden guys
look we're gonna teach you this is this
is a Capstone level course in college we
broke down the word antifa it is anti
stands for fascists or Fascism and so
it's
anti-against further against fur right
but fur is is fascist I I can't
understand though because they're saying
we don't want to be called semi-fascist
because that be bad
but I mean people who are against
fascists who we are we are trying to
project that we think are bad it's like
is that you're pissed off that you it's
pointed out that you are Fascist right
well they don't they don't like it I
think the the the reason that they're
offended or they're triggered by this
like semi-fascist or being called
fascists or whatever is because
even it like if they're like oh no guys
we're not full-blown fascists we're just
like we do we have a hint of fascism
right we're not semi-fascists but I
think the idea and whether this was
intentional or not is the like
people and the Republican Party
lawmakers who participated in January 6
or support the big lie or whatever or
you know want to take away women's
rights or want to take away you know the
rights of lgbtq people you know those
the idea that it's like well we're just
taking a little bit away we're just
controlling a little bit so we're not
full-blown fascist okay we're not bad
guy fascists we're just slight like a
hint like a spice of fascism but not a
lot like it's just like a pig like a
salt Bay kind of sprinkle well here's
why when they say semi-fascist I think
they're offended because it's now saying
well semi is a wide range it's not a
full-blown fascist versus anti-fascist
or just nothing nothing it's semi so it
now they're encompassing everything from
Nazi light like Nazi right right they're
like look I want to take a little bit of
this away not everything I'm not totally
bad I'm sorry a little bit of bad right
well I think that's why the semi-fascist
is stringing us so much because it's
literally every from nothing too fascist
is the semi-fascist Reigns so anything
you do to take away rides to control
people what they can read and and study
uh take away anything that would be you
know me as an in any level right or just
anything that I would have as a human to
March us towards a white Christian that
is why they're triggered because they're
like I only wanted to take away this one
thing I only wanted to say women
couldn't have this abortion I didn't
want to say oh you you know whatever the
full-blown extreme of that fascist rule
would be but I think that's why the semi
is so triggering for them because now
it's like oh [ __ ] it's everything from
nothing to fascist it's just a whole
blown well and I think that is the
brilliant thing that dark Brandon did
Speaker dark Brandon again there he is
again stored at the Tony michaels.com
dark Brandon t-shirts gearbox
but I think that's the Brilliance in
what he did because they're still
freaking out here it is here it is like
almost two weeks later two weeks later I
mean we have a whole cycle because they
can't talk about these top secret
documents exactly they've lost them to
have something you know that's right two
the two arguments that they have are
going to be Hunter Biden right which is
a has been a thing for years now they're
gonna talk about 100 Biden they're gonna
put the laptop and they're gonna talk
about this whole idea of semi-fascist oh
guys stop being so mean stop stop
attacking us Republicans the fascists
because our feelings are hurt and that's
not fair Tony that's not fair speaking
of fascist snowflakes because I think
the other thing that they're that they
know is that they're [ __ ] losing
because people are sick of this [ __ ] I
believe that George Will is right people
are tired of these [ __ ] Republicans
continuing these stupid culture wars
that make no sense we showed a clip last
week where on I think it was Newsmax
where they're moms of Liberty or some
[ __ ] some false ass name they're
trying to ban Peppa Pig because Peppa
Pig had two mommy pigs in it or some
[ __ ] but here is another snowflake
Senator Ron Johnson he's on Mark Levin's
show life liberty living on Fox News
again these Fox News fascist
um and listen to what Levin says at the
end though but they're really they're
butt hurt about this whole election
but again when you have the mainstream
media not willing to tell the truth when
they take just anything I say and
distorted Beyond any Refuge anything
that's recognizable uh carry the
Democrats water it's very difficult to
get the truth out how dare you play what
I say yeah this is the same [ __ ]
this is the same [ __ ] that Trump
said during his speech in Pennsylvania
which was
he goes oh I uh the argument that they
had or that they claimed to have that he
was like oh uh I said this person this
dictator Putin or whatever he was
talking about right was like oh this
person's uh you know I was talking to
another nice guy they're a great guy or
they called it President right G of
China smart right all right but then he
goes and then they say I called him
smart and it's like you you literally
just said it and you said it and you you
meant what you said and now you're
quoting the fact that you said it and
now you're upset that people quoted you
correct the video of you saying it and
you admitted to it this is more like
Marjorie Taylor green being completely
pissed off that Patriot takes right look
how dare you show the text message that
I wrote and I had yes I confirmed those
on my text messages
this is absurd lifts lifts her video
clips out you know the the 30 fascist
seconds which there's a lot of clips
that they can clip I'm sure and then
they throw them up on uh Twitter and she
gets all mad that they're being exposed
this is the same [ __ ] Ron Jon's like how
dare you know that I'm Putin's puppet
how dare you uh count on the press to
carry their water and the line distort
things for them so no it's it's a huge
challenge like I said we're are not
playing on a Level Playing Field here
Mark we haven't been for a decades quite
honestly and that's really what is uh
probably the biggest threat to America
is the fact that we do not have an
unbiased media they are advocates for
the left they are fellow Travelers and
it's a real challenge for conservatives
but you know in the end my race is
literally Truth Versus wise deception
but what this entire election is about
is fighting for freedom and it's a it's
a fight we have to wage it's everybody's
fight it's a fight we have to win Mark I
fear if we don't win your seat and
return you to the Senate that we're not
here's where it gets good and they're
going to control an awful lot of power
uh God damn right we are because every
candidate I speak to Senate candidate is
having the same situation they're being
overwhelmed with this dark money
uh dark money they mean they mean your
donations out there yes yeah they mean
your your donations they don't like
small donations they don't like
campaigns that are based on small
donations because not only does it mean
that the average normal voter believes
in that candidate yeah but it means that
there's actual support behind them not
just fake ass [ __ ] corporate support
that all these Republicans the donor
class uh goes around supporting that the
the phony corrupt media in this country
is giving massive in-kind contributions
as propagandists for the left in the
Democratic party and they've never seen
anything no we're the propagandists or
the left-wing party God damn it Mark
Levin stop stop pinning Us in with the
mainstream media we are not mainstream
media also podcast does Mark Levin
doesn't even look up he just goes like
this he's like I fear that uh if we
don't win this election seat uh that
we're gonna lose everything like the
idea that he's that they're going after
mainstream Media Fox News is [ __ ]
mainstream media okay the idea that
they're also saying that uh all news
outlets or majority news outlets are are
left leaning bull [ __ ] [ __ ] you show
me o-an uh Fox News Newsmax
CNN right the only ones that are the
other what's the other month there's
another one the the
um uh I forget what the other one is
there's another rsbn there's oh there's
the end yeah there's orange speech.com
well then you're looking at like what's
on the left you're like all right MSNBC
Kinda Yeah like I'm trying to think of I
mean I mean there's a there's there's a
lot of normies over there yeah I mean
they're not like [ __ ] all-out
socialist or anything but this whole
projection of like guys the media is not
playing Fair they're they're saying
these things that are not true which are
true and there's this dark money that's
involved which backs you and here we are
on a mainstream media channel uh News
Network and I'm trying to bash and it's
like dude
what are you talking about man you're on
Fox News which is [ __ ] huge Murdoch
the amount of money that's into this
[ __ ] machine right you guys are you
are when they built this for concern
like the entire idea the network was to
build it for conservatives let's listen
though because Mark Levin he really
wraps up in a bow what they're terrified
of here let's listen anything like this
this is better organized yep than ever
before God damn right on the side I hear
people keep talking about red white wave
and so forth and I've been cautioning
fight like hell
so Mark Levin is um is very scared of
the of the Blue Wave as he projects
because he knows it's coming they know
this [ __ ] coming well the reason why
he's coming in a couple of times
well right well I mean I mean we've had
the indication here and there's more
indication in these debates and as we
get closer to these candidates
Republicans actually debating uh
Democrats in these races I think people
are going to see more and more clearly
that these Trump candidates these
[ __ ] moglodytes these goddamn fascist
Republicans
are not qualified and fit to serve just
like Bobo here
doesn't know
what the 19th amendment is can you can
you even fathom I just I know yes I can
I can fathom a sitting congresswoman
doesn't know what the 19th amendment is
this is a person who is supposed to
[ __ ] set policy for her constituents
and she doesn't even know what the
[ __ ] 19th Amendment spells out now
she doesn't say it outright but she
doesn't know because of her response
here let's listen Okay
um
I'm Adam Frisch I'm not Nancy Pelosi
there was no
do you think we should reappeal the 19th
Amendment
do you think we should repeal the 19th
Amendment of the United States
Constitution no no that hesitation that
hesitation
like took a sec
no well I mean she was trying to make
sure it wasn't the 14th Amendment
because that's the one they [ __ ] hate
right the one they've really [ __ ] I
mean they'll get to the 19th the one
they really [ __ ] hate is the 14th
Amendment because the 14th Amendment
really makes this democracy that we are
today right and they really hate that
[ __ ] Equity under the law they
hate that [ __ ] because they
definitely want Christians and white
people and men to be way above right and
and have all the power and there's no
one else to have that equality right
like and I'm not you know
ah I hope that it wouldn't come to this
but like you've got a group of people
that want to take away rights right
you've already got at least one sitting
congresswoman who said men are the
superior gender right which is marketing
you're right right and she's out and
she's a best friend yeah and she's out
there saying well I don't know if
they're best friends because there
wasn't a little tip that they have
they're trying to compete yeah yeah but
you've got Marjorie Taylor green who
says men are the superior gender which
is then implying that like oh men can do
a better job at everything so why would
women be in power is the argument that
they're trying to make eventually coming
after women's rights the right to vote
the right to do this the right to do
this right like again you know they want
them in the kitchen they want them
having kids they want them to be
producing a stockpile of of uh
you know I don't I've I've of inventory
inventory right of being the Earth and
vessel that they are right that is the
Republican Party they're like look we
don't want you doing these other things
and and in many ways I'm like oh [ __ ]
are these women these these Congress
women are they like the martyrs to this
this wave of taking away rights from
women they're like I [ __ ] took away I
died for your right to be taken away and
in the process
I took my own right away right well
let's just saying to hear that stuff
listen to how she admits because she
says no she would not repeal it but
listen to how she admits that she
doesn't know what it is
should there be a
should there be an exception for rape
incestor the life of a mother when it
comes to Women's Health Care you talk
about security or we're just going on is
set in relation to the 19th amendment
that proves that she does not know what
the [ __ ] it is
do you know you know what the 19th
amendment is right yeah it's right oh
God okay like the the fact that she's
willing well when she's like okay I
won't take away these rights from women
to have the right to vote right right
and then she goes so rape and incest of
an abortion is that related yeah but it
doesn't rights to vote like well because
she's trying to figure out what the 19th
amendment is here I think she's like
yeah um if you if you really wanted to
make the argument I could say right now
that those two are connected and the way
that those two are connected are the
done in the way that if a baby is born
and that baby is a female then she has
the right to vote eventually when she
turns 18. right so like in some weird
back ass way I could see someone trying
to make that logic work to say well if
there's no 19th or like well if you
abort the baby then they don't have the
19th Amendment right but it's insane
because that's not what she's trying to
argue what she's saying is she doesn't
understand what the [ __ ] the 19th
amendment is and so she doesn't she has
no clue that the 19th Amendment which
I'm curious what she thinks the 19th
amendment is well and again she because
there's one of the Amendments that they
a hate which is the 14th Amendment right
and then there's two that they really
like the first and the second they don't
know what they say well one two and five
well now five yeah five is what they use
one and two is what they love 14 is what
they hate she has no [ __ ] idea the
only reason why she's a goddamn
congresswoman in the first place is
because of the 19th Amendment no clue no
clue that it gave the women right to
vote well she also doesn't believe that
the constitution isn't evolving she
doesn't believe that it's organic it's
not even she wouldn't believe in any of
the Amendments right like any of them
any of them it just it's well that's
where I'm like dude can someone please
like just give take her to a civics
class but no it's the first day be like
no we're gonna go through these
amendments is that I don't think we're
gonna Define what an amendment is and
what really want to torture people in
the class like that it's just a
one-on-one too now it's just a
one-on-one here's what happened yeah the
classes the classes boom she gets
enrolled into the class but no one else
is a role because everyone else
understands what the [ __ ] is going on
with the Constitution and the Amendments
but also while they're there they also
just give a like a little bonus lesson
which is talking about fascism and
anti-fascism and one antifa really
stands for and then it's not just antifa
the word it's part of a larger word that
isn't a group is it an organization but
it's an ideology it's a belief that I
don't like fascists yeah I don't like
when people take rights away from people
for no reason other than who they are
speaking of fascist
um here's
some people are saying that maybe this
America First policy Institute these
America First Nazis these America First
fascists Mike has a here update this is
probably the reason Trump flew into DC
to attend this event today with the
quote honorable because that's what it
says here uh is Honorable yeah okay
um Jared Kushner so that's what this
says here is the honorable Jared Kushner
apparently he's got that book he's
selling so this is I can tell you Ivanka
texted me again the other day she did oh
she did and the text says let's say I
could think him in like Friday or
Saturday
uh it says
it was on Saturday Okay and she wrote
Ivanka Trump Colin so you know it's her
this is this is really this is this
isn't fake you're not no this is a real
text that I got from because you signed
up on yeah because I signed up and it
goes my burner number Ivanka Trump Colin
my husband Jared wrote an incredible
book about my father's presidency and
shares Insight on the many historic
things that were accomplished during his
four years in the White House claim your
signed copy and then I'm sure if I click
on the link it's going to Temp you to a
page that then says in order to secure
it I have to donate oh of course of
course Jared Kushner signed a copy of
his own book for you I [ __ ] doubt
that I think it's a printed signature so
you can go [ __ ] yourself uh Jared signed
a limited number of copies for his new
book break in history a White House
Memoir and he wants you to have one just
contribute
75 or more and we'll mail you a copy of
breaking history of White House Memoir
that Jared Kushner signed for you and
then when you go in it's it's defaulted
to the 150 and it's animated to be like
do 150 even though they said just don't
well they asked for 150 bucks yeah God
damn I mean they just ride out of the
Gateway it's just boom boom boom and
then of course they're you know opting
in make it monthly
um and then they then they also ask you
too they ask you in addition they said
would you like to make another donation
even before I even made a donation
they're like would you like to make
another donation even though you haven't
donated yet right well that's that's
fantastic that's fantastic
um you know let's let's do one more
thing before we go here I want to talk
about
um this uh the case that they're trying
to make this morning about these
documents Kate has it laid out here this
is what Trump's legal team's response to
the doj request for a stay they're
trying to get um this this uh stop on on
on reviewing these documents they're
trying to stay this or request and this
is their this is an image of their
of their argument uh dude they're not
top secret prove that they're prove that
they are prove it yeah but they're but
the argument also is we need this
special Master to determine if they're
classified or not and it's like which
that's not what a special Master does
the special Master only determines if
the [ __ ] [ __ ] they took isn't isn't
pertinent and isn't evidence is attorney
client privilege or executive privilege
that's what it that special Masters for
and they've already done that right
that's why and also the idea that
they're like oh look we need a special
master so now we need another person
with security clearance
if it wasn't
Declassified
or rather if it was actually
Declassified then somebody would not
need security clearance that is a good
point and to review this did you see who
they who they nominated
they had to nominate Trump
no no no actually they they nominated
two people that you would be like why
one of them was the [ __ ] fisa judge
that gave the fisa warrant on Carter
page
and the reason why yeah the reason
that's who they not and the reason why
is because they knew they had to have
someone who could look at these
documents to be a special Master right
and what better than a retired judge who
was in a fisa court because a retired
federal judge in a fisa court would
would have a security clearance and
there's only God damn there can't be
more than two maybe three dozen people
in the entire country that could
actually do this job that aren't a
government employee already that that
don't currently hold a position that
would probably you know have some kind
of conflict of interest here that are
retired that have that type of security
clearance there can't be more than a
couple dozen people right to choose from
so they actually they actually and they
nominated the [ __ ] judge who is she
the fisa worn against Carter page and
the other thing that they did is they
were like do the government's going to
pay for this whole thing and the
government's like [ __ ] we are oh yeah
but there we are you're the one who
wants this now
well this is that moment when you're at
dinner right and you're like oh man
protect my wallet so great exactly and
you're like you're both reaching for
your bag
yeah you're like oh [ __ ] and you're like
sorry all I got is my phone he's like oh
well I've got I got cash app and I got
venmo and it's like oh you know what
those apps are broken goddamn 20 20. I
just have to be I can't make it
you know what but now that look at my
phone look at the time I need to go I
need to order myself a car to go but I
don't have any money so can you cover
the bill but no I mean like that's the
idea that's going on here is there Trump
is so broke and I come I put this online
and people like oh he's not broke he's
no dude he's [ __ ] he is a joke
definitely not a billionaire I think
uh
uh Leticia James revealed that he had
last year or 2020 revealed that he had
like 90 million potentially but I don't
even know if that was completely
verified well right the reason why he
claims to be a billionaire is because he
likely holds close to a billion or over
a billion dollars worth of real estate
but he owes so much [ __ ] money on it
he didn't actually own it the banks own
it that's like his former attorney Cohen
who said uh
who said
to get on the Forbes list they didn't
even send any documents they were on a
Forbes call years years ago when he was
younger and they was like oh yeah I'm
looking at his bank statement right now
and the bank statement says like 500
million or some [ __ ] like that
nobody verified it they just took it
they just took the lawyer's word for it
and trusted on the phone call and
they're like yeah this is this sounds
good to me all right cool we'll put him
in the Forbes list this is like the
modern day version of having a zoom call
you're like well just show it to us like
oh the camera's not working
I mean it's you know it's it's basically
Rudy Giuliani which is like oh look we
have the documents we'll give them to
you eventually it's like dude I [ __ ]
need them I'll give you the proof once
you do what I say that yeah for the
proof uh Kyle has the motion here um he
tweeted uh the the motion Kyle Chaney
did Justin Trump files 21 page
opposition to doj request for stay of
Judge cannons order
here's the introduction it talks about
it here but he goes on to point out in
the thread
here's the one that I want to see uh it
says the government contends that
President Trump can have no such
interest in the
purported quote classified records again
the air quote thing they're trying to
say they're not classified but again
this is the best part the government has
not proven these records remain
classified that issue is to be
determined later so they're they're
trying in this motion to kick the actual
reason why doj is trying to get to stay
because doj's saying hey
it the it's these are this is classified
government documents these are not his
yeah he doesn't have executive privilege
over him because he's not the president
and he doesn't have a turning client
privilege
over government documents that are
classified government documents again
Gabe I believe this wholeheartedly I
believe why he thinks these are his is
because some of these [ __ ] documents
have his name in them they have his
[ __ ] naming them that's why he thinks
they're his yeah he's like oh my name
okay right but again you know this idea
that our government only exists in a
paper physical paper form like we don't
have
servers and servers and servers you know
in the Pentagon in you know in Secure
locations around the world that you know
there's literally a team that is in
charge of protecting that you know that
data
so the idea that
Trump is like well they're my documents
I want them well if that were the case
then we would have given you the actual
original copies that are on the servers
right and two
the idea that it's like oh well if I
took them then no one has I'm like how
[ __ ] dumb are you I know you think
that if you take the physical copy no
one's like oh yeah well we've got the
actual original source file
on record some you just have the copy of
that [ __ ]
well so and Hillary Clinton was talking
about this like on The View the other
day where like someone would come in
with a handcuff briefcase and [ __ ] to
show it yeah and then as soon as they
were done they had to stick it back in a
lock box then with its handcuffed to him
and [ __ ] like that but read this part of
this of this motion it says to ex to the
extent president Trump they call him
president not former president he's a
[ __ ] former president yeah may have
categorized certain of the seasons
material as personal during his
pregnancy you don't just get to go wave
your Big Mac stain hand and go all these
are Declassified and they're all mine
now yeah like that's not a thing but
also it's like a thing and that goes to
your point of like you know these
documents probably mention his name so
he goes my name they're mine they're
about me so they're my property they're
they're my personal property but that is
not how it works just because her name
is mentioned whether you did something
illegal or we had [ __ ] on you and you
try to get rid of it again
you just have the physical copy we don't
want that physical copy out there
because it's so sensitive we have the
originals and we know that it's missing
because we
and to and the other thing too is like
the idea that they're like look if we
take the physical copy no one will know
what's missing it's not like you're in
class and a teacher print out a bunch of
extra copies and it's like all right
hand these out and uh just leave the
extras on the desk no they are they know
they log specifically how many times
that [ __ ] was printed who had it what
folder is in when it was transported
what time from A to B they know all of
that stuff so when they know later on
that oh look a thing didn't come back
with the original documents or wasn't
put in the original place or this person
didn't report it
they know exactly a long line where that
person where it dropped like who dropped
the ball
and now they know well there's another
copy that's missing out there we need to
get it and most likely it's Trump and
it's when it confirmed our assumption or
or our our theory is that it was Trump
until they come after and he's like no
no they're my documents they're personal
well all this [ __ ] all this [ __ ] is
dangerous for any president to think
that they have that power not just Trump
but uh the danger here and I want to uh
do this one last clip I want to show
this clip because I want people to know
the danger that you're in if you think
you you can just sit this one out now
Christopher Webb he actually Chris put
the um the video the Box video yeah the
Box video counting them well he didn't
put the video he just zoomed in and
counted the boxes that we showed earlier
and I want to give him credit for for
giving us a closure view I love this
video that's why I put it in the clip we
had
um but Chris here says this dude is nuts
this guy is Mark Wayne which you got two
first names that are combined that's
that's a [ __ ] red flag you know they
say you can't you can't trust people
with two first names this guy doesn't
have two first names he's got two first
names that are combined it's all one
word that's really important uh he's a
republican he is an elected official
he's a congressman says companies aren't
welcome in Oklahoma if they support
employees who need to travel out of
state for abortions God damn it they
passed a law to take away your rights
and they're not going to put up with
anyone that won't adhere to that law
listen to this crazy [ __ ] this is what
they want folks not just in Oklahoma
he's at the [ __ ] United States
capital listen or corporations to say
that they are literally going to pay for
an employee to go to a different state
to murder their baby
that's those are those are businesses
that I don't choose to associate with
and I would hope a lot of people would
feel the same because if you want to do
business in our state then respect our
laws if you don't want to do business or
state then just do businesses in those
States that's going to offer those
heinous abortions
otherwise
get out our state question mark so they
want to kick businesses out of their
state because they know that their their
employees would need a life-saving
medical procedure well they don't want
to support anyone you know again going
back to the fascist regime which is
taking away the rights and making sure
that no one even when you say hey it's
in the right of a company the private
rights like they should be just like
nope no one should no one no one should
have this right no private company no
private entity should even be able to
give that right or access to an employee
or whatever it might be right especially
which is funny because [ __ ] Hobby
Lobby [ __ ] and all that stuff of like
you know or like I'm the you know I
don't want to make a cake for a gay
couple and all this [ __ ] but when
it's reversed on them right they hate
that oh whoa whoa whoa whoa guys guys
what do you do what are you doing what
are you doing no no you can't do that
you can't but they but they want to send
businesses out of their state they want
to hurt the economy right because
they're bigots companies are like if I
can't afford it fine I'll go somewhere
yes I have to you know move my life but
the other thing too is I think there's a
campaign going on right now when you
know because Texas is between Texas
Florida and California Texas and Florida
is like come come here come here turns
out you pay more taxes in Texas than you
do in California wow wow yeah well
listen to Dark Brandon and keep calling
these people semi-fascists and keep
calling them out and while you're at it
go to store.they Tony michaels.com and
we're air your support for dark Brandon
and his semi-fascist language I think he
should be more outright here I think he
should drop the semi and just call them
fascist I think that's what he should do
but so go to store.donymichaels.com and
get your dark Brandon merch also if you
want to support pro-democracy speech
which you should you should lean into
your democracy if you want to support
this show we appreciate it rather you
retweet share it with your family your
friends give us a like or a comment if
you want to do monetary support
support.tonymichaelspod.com or you can
use the QR code the links are all down
in the description don't forget to
subscribe to the podcast here that also
helps us out with support and make sure
to go follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod
because we do a poll there every week
bone end of the week and if you want to
support to go download us if you want to
listen to our beautiful voices while
you're running while you're cooking
while you're grocery shopping while
you're at work while you're in the car
Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directories leave us a great review
while you're there and subscribe
Gabe it's bound to be a huge Newsweek
they keep piling up here
I don't think it's good we also have the
date for the next chance well well I
actually I have been told that maybe
just maybe there might be another one
before that it depends uh it depends so
but but the official next date is the
28th of September so don't forget don't
forget to keep an eye on that that's why
you want to follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod so you keep up to date on
all those happenings
and keep watching here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours on YouTube and Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from at Facebook
the books of face
same time same place tomorrow let's
let's do this tomorrow same time
same place Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon